What happens if you are unfit for work and
are not fired or reassigned to another position.
So if you are deemed unfit to hold your position,
the employer has one month to act,
either by offering you 1 position adapted to your condition,
you by initiating 1 dismissal procedure in the
event that none of his actions are undertaken.
After this time,
your employer is required to resume payment of your salary
even if you are unable to work because of your inability.
Employees who are declared unfit are on
sick leave immediately after this declaration.
This situation is quite common.
The Court of Cassation ruled in a judgment of March 1deux-mille-vingt-trois and
if no solution for reclassification or dismissal has been found after 1 month,
the employer must not only resume the payment of the salary,
but also cannot discount the daily
allowances of the social security of this world.
As a result,
you may end up with 1 higher income during this period.
This rule acts as a sanction against the
employer who fails in his duty to reclassify or dismiss.
If you have any questions,
please feel free to ask me in the comments.